all right y'all before we say goodbye I
have one more great story to share this
is what I'm
[Applause]
liking this Sunday America will be glued
to their televisions I one of them as
Patrick Mahomes and the Kansas City
Chiefs battle the Baltimore Ravens for
the AFC Championship this is going to be
an incredible game I'm very excited off
the field go ahead off the field
Patrick's wife Britney is leading her
own battle this one against childhood
allergies very important she is here
today so give it up for Britney mom
nice to have you on the show I love your
Johnny Cash black thank you thank you so
you had a scary experience that kind of
made this all happen right yes yes so my
oldest daughter Sterling um when she was
younger she had an allergic reaction to
milk so when I had my second child my
daughter did that Patrick Mahomes II I
have to say his real name or his dad
will get mad his name is Patrick we call
him bronze um so when he was you know
start able to start eating food we kind
of introduced some things you know we
got through milk we got through eggs we
were on first day of peanuts um within
minutes you know he kind of started to
get fussy so I thought you know he was
just tired let's go to bed early um I
took his diaper off and he you know had
hives everywhere within minutes it began
to swell and cover his whole body and
you know in the back of my head I'm like
oh my God it's going to his throat we
need to go to the emergency room um we
went to the emergency room and he was
fine yeah but that's a really big thing
like I can't even imagine for a kid like
having to do that to my kid but it is it
is cool to know that about you know
having the avue is that what you that's
one you use yes and it so what's cool
about the avq is it speaks to you so it
tells you what to do it walks you
through it and then it does remind you
to call 911 at the end so yeah um okay
so I have to ask are you you're excited
for Sunday oh I'm very excited but
you're you're originally are you
originally Texan I am okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay me too um how
hard was that the switch over
um I was not a Cowboys fan you weren't
neither was okay my manager group in
Texas was not a Cowboys fan I was like
tror I wasn't but I appreciate them
because I am Texas at heart and they
work hard and they are a great team yeah
shout out to you for being a fan but yes
I um but go Chiefs yeah go Chiefs I love
the game I love watching so much you
have a lot of talented people on the
Chiefs so it's a fun time yes your
husband was one of them okay and thank
you um I'm loving your post right now so
usually is the time we give our guests
$1,000 I think she's fine she doesn't
need the money they're doing well um so
we usually give a$ thousand dollar
though courtesy of um our partner pilot
pin makers of G2 the go-to pin and the
Kelly Clarkson show but today it is
going to someone in the audience
so everyone look at the screen if you
call on
your you get the
money oh where are you at where are
you hello hi what is your name Kaa Kia
with the sexy name as well okay okay
what are what are you going to do with
the money um you get half
oh friendship okay I like it yeah need
those kind of friends in your life
that's amazing that's amazing well what
are y'all going to do with it you going
to do something fun with it I pay a bill
May pay a bill and then have fun with
the other portion yeah yeah definitely
yeah saying all right well thanks to all
our guests this hour Jamie Oliver Tom
Hollander je Kenny Jac Andy H have a
great day and it's not Chang
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home h